hello
this is a video tour of the united
states green party map
here you have the map you can hover over
the state parties
and click into them you can hover over
the local parties and click into them
you can hover over the candidates and
click into them
all of the candidates who are currently
running for office are
displayed on the map you can scroll down
and you can see the contact information
for the united states green party you
can see the banner ad for
howie walker's presidential campaign
with angela
we can click into the list of the
politicians at this level we
list the national politicians only that
would be president vice president and
congressional candidates
and we can see the list of parties some
of whom also have
met their own maps this website is
organized as a tree
you can think of it as a file system but
really it's running on top of an
object-oriented database
so let's drill into the tree here we
have california california
is the largest green party in the united
states
most technologically advanced they've
really pushed this map very far
they've chosen to display images of all
of the candidates
you can click into those you can here's
an ad menu
so the anonymous browser can submit a
politician
of an organization an online event an ad
an in-person event
and then the admins will get an email
and
approve it or not california also has
its map
all the contact information they've
chosen not to display a banner
and there's also a list of all the
candidates
in california which would of course
include the presidential candidates
and a list of the local parties in
california
so let's drill further into this map
we're going to take a look at jake
tonkel
and jake tonkel is actually in santa
clara
so let's click into it now at the local
party level you only see the candidates
you can vote for
and so in this case it's the president
vice president and jake tonkel
um again the ad menu is there all the
contact information for the santa clara
party
and the lists of local politicians
and uh parties so let's
click drill into this further into jake
tonkle
so jake tonk has done something very
interesting you can see his photograph
here
and now this database supports data
inheritance
so the entire branch of the tree for
jake tonkel is all going to have his
image we can go ahead and endorse jake
tonkel
logs us in with google since i'm an
administrator i get a bunch more
permissions here
and we can continue to drill down into
this tree you can see the twitter
everyone's twitter feed it's at the
bottom of each page um let's continue
down into the tree we're going to jake
tonkel has a team tonkal virtual meeting
and at it they're going to be showing
two videos
so we've just seen uh another content
type which is a virtual event
and we've seen this as a content type
which is a youtube video
and as you can see there's not that much
content on this uh there's not much text
describing this and so maybe somebody
would want to edit
and add some text to it so all the pages
on this website have this very nice
swizzy week
text ender we can paste in some lorem
ipsum and then you can use
bold italic strikethrough save and view
it so just a typical wysiwyg a ck editor
actually
editor and then all that shows up on the
production website
immediately but whoops um this is the
production website we don't want alarm
ipsum on there we need to get rid of it
fortunately any modern content
management system is going to have a
history view
so here we can go and restore the
history and view it again
and you can see all of that's gone so
let's see where we are in the tree
we started as a root you didn't see that
the howie hawkins map server the green
party us map and directory green party
of california green party of santa clara
jake tonkel team tonkal virtual meetup
and educational equity
video we're seven levels deep in this
tree if each
level has seven items you're gonna come
to about five million items in the
street so you can manage a vast amount
of
information using a hierarchy and yet
people don't get lost they kind of
intuitively understand where they are
but you do have a problem with people
stepping on each other's toes you do
need a good security system
so let's go back up to jake tonkel's
virtual medium
he can assign somebody to manage this
branch of the tree
editors so he can assign one or two
people to manage this branch of the tree
and we won't go ahead and do that
um but then they have permission to add
this and recursively up the tree people
can
assign permissions or remove permissions
from people below them in the tree
now if you see here he actually has two
videos maybe he doesn't like those so
there's a management view
and we can delete one of the items and
it's gone for good from the website
oops but again i messed up we really
want that on the production website and
there's no history view because the
object isn't there
but there is a transaction view so we
can look at transactions
and we can undo the transaction
and now when we go back to this page and
reload it you'll see that the video is
back there
[Music]
okay continuing back up the tree
um actually let's take a look at jake
tonkel uh we
this interesting contact so when you do
contact well who do you want to contact
you want to contact jake tonkel or maybe
the green party of california or the
green party u.s map and director you're
the howie hawkins map server
so it's kind of this hierarchy of
contact information
um let's see going up a level okay so
back up to california
now if you're california um you have a
big problem because you're not just
managing one or two things you have this
huge amount of candidates
and local parties to manage and so we
look at their management view it's much
more complex
so you can think of this as a file
system browser well obviously it isn't
because here we have the class
so this is the python class it's running
on a persistent python launcher database
and unlike a file browser you can
actually move things up and down
but i better put that back or nothing
from california would be upset at me for
messing up this organization
uh you can click to view an object
because
and then they all have multiple views
you can click into and edit an object
and of course we can select all and um
there are options to rename
retitle rebuilt which does both of those
cut copy delete paste
okay so that's the management view and
let's go let's
look at that again let's go up one more
level and the other thing you have to do
when you're dealing with
a large community is you have to manage
all of the volunteers
so here we have progress and we can see
which items have been added recently
which items have been edited recently
some are new and some are edited in this
column and you can actually see this one
so somebody's added something through
the web it needs to be approved
i will check out what exactly what
happened there after this
video is over
and you can see also i'm an editor so i
have an option to add a lot more stuff
when we go back up to um
one of the things you can add is a link
so here we have a whole
section of branch of the tree on defund
the police
and you can see all the different links
and there's also
i can do this here's a big list of
climate change links so here you
have literally hundreds of links
generally this kind of information is
hidden on the web it's very difficult to
find it took me years to find this
but you find it here on our websites and
next up
um here we have another feature which is
the newest items
so for any right now it does for the
whole tree but very soon for any branch
of the tree you'll be able to see which
items were most recently added to the
tree
and so this really acts as a news source
for the green party
here we have a very another interesting
feature howie hawkins
so this is a branch of the tree and
because it's structured as a tree we can
take any branch of the tree and turn it
into an instant website
so when a candidate runs for office they
just fill out a form with some critical
information
and then boom they have an instant
website that don't have to wait around
can start being a politician right away
and you can do that also for for parties
state parties or local parties
okay there you have it united states
green party map thank you very much
you